when you like create that bond with
someone it was more like he was my best
friend over everything
so um when we did end up
taking our separate ways we wanted to
make sure that we
remained that like best friendship that
we had
well let's talk about this new song your
debut song it's called
pain and you actually wrote the song
yourself
which is amazing
kind of walk me through exactly what
inspired the lyrics
um well i wrote it during like a really
like vulnerable time
um i was dealing with a lot like
heartbreak
hate um on social media like loss of
friendships and i was just going through
a lot like i moved out here
um 17 without my family just a really
hard time and i kind of wanted to
express how i was feeling um with my
song
because a lot of people can't really see
how i truly feel
through like a 15 second tick tock video
so yeah
i basically just like walked in the
studio inside of the piano and just
started crying and pouring my heart out
and then that's how it came
it's such a beautiful song is it about
your breakup from
josh it's a part of it
just a lot going on especially like the
hate
the breakup obviously made it harder but
yeah
you you do say in this song um should i
say i'm sorry did i mess it up
what why were you questioning things or
why was that what you were asking
yourself
it's like every time i go through like a
hard time
i feel like i'm the one that did
something wrong so that was kind of me
like opening up and
like explaining that like i feel guilty
for
a lot of the things that happen in my
life so yeah
that's where that came from i'm just
really hard on myself i'm a super like
hard person
and i don't know i always blame myself
for everything
so i just kind of want to show that
because
like whenever i get upset i always feel
like it's my fault when it's not
so well not to get too personal with you
but
i did talk to josh last week did you see
this
a favorite thing about nessa uh i think
that just like our humor is very similar
when
when
we like joke around together so that's
like why i wanted to keep her as a
friend because like i think she's very
funny
and that i just like laughed very hard
when i'm around her
i thought he was very sweet about you
did you agree
yes he's sweet how do you feel about
where things
stand with you too um i'm really happy i
mean like we're friends and i just love
that we're mature enough to
keep our friendship after everything and
that's just what's important to me
do you see yourself ever getting back
together with him because he
he didn't say yes or no either way so
i'm curious only time will tell but
right now i'm just
really enjoying us being friends was it
hard i feel like things became so public
just be
like giving your guys's breakup and to
have everyone sort of talking about it
and have something to say and you
mentioned you got hate on social media
um how did you how do you feel about
that and will you try to be more private
moving forward
yeah i mean um like i am a teenager
so i'm gonna deal with like everyday
teenage things and it's hard when i have
like a million
eyes on me that critique and put their
word on everything that happens
so like you hear everyone's
like words like in your ear and it gets
to you um
but i feel like i'm not
gonna say like i'm gonna be more private
but um
more careful as to where i draw that
line from my personal life and my social
media life
do you wanna stay single for a little
bit now
um yeah i mean i am doing new things and
i am focusing on myself
and i just love where things are going
and i want to keep it that way
so to appease the fans and i ask
josh this is well i think you know
what's coming i mean do you have a
favorite thing
about him um i just love how supportive
he is
no matter what yeah he's always there
for me and always like supports whatever
i do
so i really appreciate that what does he
think of the song pain
he loves it sometimes it's kind of
awkward when he listens to it because
like he knows
it's part of it um yeah but
yeah he loves it he's like supported
so much and i am just so grateful for
that but
he's been really sweet why was it
important for you guys to remain
friends after everything because you
guys both
seemed like that's that was a very
important thing yeah
um we've been like
so close for like a year
maybe over that and um when you like
create
that bond with someone it was more like
he was my best friend over everything
so um when we did end up
taking our separate ways we wanted to
make sure that we
remained that like best friendship that
we had
um which is like super important because
it's hard to let someone that was so
important in your life like go like that
um and we did it
so all right
[Music]
living under such a microscope now like
what have you learned most about
yourself um
i feel like i've always saw myself as a
super weak
person but this like past few months
i have been through so much and
like went through so much kind of like
hard times that i realized that i am
strong and that i can really get through
things
um so like i honestly feel like i've
been through the worst right now
so i feel like in the future i'll be
prepared and
that's really been helpful for me